reunidos frente a la asamblea estos
paquistaníes acudieron a manifestar su
alegría para ellos la destitución del
primer ministro a brand hand es una
buena noticia
estamos aquí para celebrar la victoria
de la democracia en rne kan hizo falsas
promesas ahora ha llegado su momento
final
una satisfacción igualada por el enfado
de los partidarios del primer ministro
depuesto muchos salieron a la calle para
apoyar a jan nos manifestaremos
pacíficamente el partido está ya quién
sabe volverá al gobierno con una mayoría
de dos tercios no tendremos miedo y no
agacharemos la cabeza el domingo pasado
en brand hand disolvió la asamblea
nacional para evitar una moción de
censura una medida juzgada como ilegal
por el tribunal supremo y que precipitó
su caída al denunció un complot urdido
por eeuu en castigo a su acercamiento a
china y rúsia antes de la votación el
presidente de la asamblea y el
partidario del primer ministro dimite el
nuevo jefe de gobierno será nombrado el
lunes el líder de la oposición shahbaz
sharif es el favorito es con que
queremos curar las heridas y los dolores
del país nos vengaremos no infligir
hemos injusticias no detendremos a nadie
y no encarcelar hemos a nadie sin motivo
solo la ley se aplicará en branham como
todos los primeros ministros anteriores
no podrá terminar su mandato el futuro
jefe de gobierno tendrá que enfrentarse
a muchos retos dos de los cuales son
primordiales reactivar la economía y
luchar contra los grupos terroristas que
multiplican sus atentados en pakistán